Okay, so let us pick up from where we
left. Uh we have this solution proposed
by Badano at all with this idea that
want to learn the similarity or score
that how well a decoder state ST aka the
query should attend to then to an
encoder state hi or the key value. This
is done using a tiny neural network an
MLP with one hidden layer and a tangent
hyperbolic activation. So let us look
closer at this formulation. We have WQ
and W K as the learn projections that
map queries ST and keys HI into this
common alignment space of dimension DH.
So note that this let us compare SD and
hi from uh different sizes. Let's say SD
can be um the decoder dimension and hi
uh the encoder dimension and not
necessarily the same. So that's a nice
feature. So again this let us compare
objects of different size. So you can uh
imagine uh that uh this rotate and scale
both s and hi in a way that they are
semantically matching then it will
inject some nonlinear interaction using
the tangent hyperbolic between the
projected vectors that enables a reacher
non by linear matching. So beyond let's
say a dot product or a cosine similarity
and then we have this VA that is
basically a feature selector in this
alignment space. So after computing the
DH dimensional match features now we
have a vector of features with DH
dimension following these steps here.
But then later we also choose those
features that actually matter in this
alignment. So VA help helps us to do
that to assign some positive and
negative importance to each one of these
hidden features produced by calling the
tangent hyperbolic. Okay. So note that
this is defined for T and I but we are
going to share the parameters of this
MLP for all pairs of TNI. Remember that
this is very similar to CNN logic that
we are using or learning a kernel but we
are using the same kernel across all
pairs. Okay. So let's look at why this
works. So first of all it removes the
bottleneck that we discussed. So this
decoder no longer compresses this entire
source into a single vector and instead
it adapts a context
uh dynamic con context ct at each step.
So now let us call this uh E
TI
and then we can uh we can make this uh
tension weights alpha t and I that is
basically a soft max of this. Like I
said this gives us the CT and the
decoder uses this CT and the SD to
predict the next token. So again we know
what's nice about this soft alignment.
This weights or the soft alignments
behave like a like differentiable
alignment from this target position t to
the source position I. So the paper from
showed that using this additive
attention
significantly advanced the original seek
to seek LSTDM breakthrough
uh by Ilia and others. So now let us
look at how can we implement this and
before coding I want to take a closer
look on the scalability of this additive
attention.
We know that uh our GPUs and TPUs are
optimized for this dense matrix
multiplication.
However, additive attention requires
this kind of complex fused operation.
It's not pure matrix multiplication.
So if we could do the same thing but
only with pure matrix multiplication, we
could achieve massive speed ups and of
course scalability which is something
that we need for training large models.
So looking at this here, let's see what
prevents us from this scaling up and
going toward pure multiplication. So I'm
going to rewrite this just for the sake
of discussing this computation aspects.
So let's assume this we have t as the
target length or the number of tokens
for example in the French translation
and n to be the source length. Okay. So
now we have WQ ST from T1 to T uh which
is in R TH
right
and on the other side we have W K hi
from I 1 to N in this the pair wise
hidden feature will be first let's write
the first component
H of I'm going to make my notation
easier here by calling this guy a t from
t1 to t or shorthanded by matrix a and
this guy let's call it b from i 1 to n
or b right so the tangent hyperbolic
that we discussed will be a t plus b
plus some bias term and we know that
this guy is in our dh right let's call
this h now e t and I will be the feature
selector multiplied by this H. Okay. So
computing this
naively
uh requires u T and DH tensor uh and of
course an elementwise nonlinearity in
10h
and a reduction here. So this pattern is
extremely broadcast heavy. It is memory
bound and it's not really using our GPU
tensor core units. Like I said, what we
really want is this generalized
matrix multiplication. This way, if we
do it, we can leverage all of this GPU
cores and we basically can achieve a hit
peak or the maximum number of floating
point operation. So note that this
nonlinearity plus these two is not
separable in our uh GPU. So I encourage
you to look at this and see why it's not
possible to separate and distribute it
over the GPU cores. Okay. So let's move
toward this uh kind of matrix
multiplication version of this attention
computation that we are going to call it
an inner product or a dotproduct
attention. Okay. So we want to do the
same thing but only with dot product. So
how to do it? Basically, I like to do
this calculation here
or this computation of attention of this
guy here in a way that I'm not dealing
with any of these two. But we know that
nonlinearity does something for us. It
really enriches this latent space and
finds better alignment. And also this VA
helps to add another level of uh feature
selection. So we need to somehow build
up this nonlinearity in our uh
architecture in a way that uh we
basically separate the building up of
nonlinearity
to achieve richer features and then once
we have that in this rich feature space
then we can do inner products without
the need of infusing additional
nonlinearity. Okay. So we'll explain
what I mean by that. Okay. So let us uh
state the problem that we want to solve.
We want to find the similarity between
two vector right the query and the key.
In our case for example Q was S of T and
K was H of I right. But we want to do it
in a way that uh the when we are
computing this uh payer attention we
only want to use uh inner product
right
between SD and hi or some function of
them right I mean we can do any
operation we want as long as it's on
them separately not under interaction so
let's call this functions fi
Okay. So if we have this then we can
just compute the inner product. Let's
use the classic inner product style
notation. We want to find phi
uh here that in a way that the inner
product give gives us a kernel that is
the most relevant kernel for our task.
So we want to learn this vice
and this will give us the similarity
that we want right. So where we saw this
if you remember in support vector
machine for example we had this problem
of separation of let's say a two group
of data points like this
with a linear plane or line. So this is
a two-dimensional
space let's say let's call it x1 and x2.
So in support vector machine we what we
did was to find a higher dimensional
space let's say
fi 1 of x 5 2 of x
and 53 of x
where things are
separated. Let's say here we have this
separation
like this.
So now with a simple plane between them
we can separate them. Um you can think
of fs for example here in this case we
have x was x1 and x2
but fs are I don't know some form of
functions of x1's and so on. Okay. So
note that we can have any function here.
For example, it can be sin of x1,
cosine of x1,
x2,
anything. So how many of the functions
we have in the world? We have infinite.
And as long as we can compute the inner
product, we are happy.
And in this higher dimensional space,
things are easier to separate. we can
employ linear operation to for example
separate them, rotate them and uh align
them together and that's the idea. So we
need to build up a feature space using
nonlinearity that we want that on this
SD and hi and lift them
from this lower dimension to this higher
dimension where things are easier to
manipulate uh using our linear
operations or linear algebra and dot
product is one of them and as long as we
are in this space we can dot product. So
that's the the real idea here. Okay. So
let's go back to our seek to seek RNN
where we had type of RNN layer. Uh we
had uh several activation within the RNN
that adds nonlinearity to the encoder
and decoder states. And given that
nonlinearity
and some rotation of them and the inner
product of this
will do what we want. But like I said
this is all relying on the case that we
already have enough nonlinearity here or
we already lift this up to this higher
dimension. So that's the idea. So we
need the nonlinearity. We cannot only do
this rotation. Okay. Later you will see
when we remove even the RNN or CNN
encoders and we only do attention we
have to have some form of feed forward
neural network that injects this uh
nonlinearity or lifting role. Okay. So
remember when we go to self attention
where we only have attention we still
need some form of feed forward to infuse
enough nonlinearity
uh to lift everything up and then in
this higher dimensional space we can do
this inner product. We can also show
this from the previous kernel view. So
assume a a Gaussian kernel let's say a
kernel between Q and K that is written
like this right with some kernel widths
which is a function of this norm. So if
we write this down it is basically Q
minus 2 QT K. So this is uh an inner
product right. So the idea is this is
equivalent to this. So why? Because we
know that later when we send this guy to
soft max.
Soft max is invariant to shifts. Meaning
that for example if you have soft max of
a q let's say ki plus some constant this
will be similar to soft max of a q ki.
Okay. So anything that is constant here
and not a function of ki that changes
with I will vanish. Okay. So let's go
back here.
Well this guy is a function of Q. So it
will vanish in a soft max. How about
this guy? Well, we know that this is KI,
right? So this shouldn't really vanish.
But the thing is in in attention we do
this layer norm which makes all of this
features to be normalized meaning that
they all have the same norm. So all of
the kis has the same norm. So ki has the
same norm as kj when i and j is not the
same. This is happening because that's
how we adjust them. This is the layer
norm. So in that case this is also a
constant and the whole thing reduces to
the inner product. So we want to
maximize similarity we minimizing the
kernel or the distance and maximizing
the dot product because of this
negative. Okay. So this is another way
of looking at this. Okay. Okay. So it's
important to know that after this
calculation we said that a QA basically
same as QT K but we also want to make
sure that we are taking care of the the
variance here because we can have a high
dimension for these vectors like we
discussed. So the vectors let's say they
are living in DK and the inner product
basically is happening in DK. So even if
Q and K both the expectation
is zero, they're centered and even their
variance is one. We do this scaling,
right? The variance of the dot product
is the summation of all of these
variances, right? Which is the
dimension. And when dimension goes
higher, this variance goes higher. So
how to control this? We basically make
sure that this guy is divided by DK. So
we want to make sure the variance of
this is not exploding with DK. And to do
that it's enough to
divided by square root of DK. So this is
the notion of scale.product
and using this now if you compute the
variance the variance will be one. So
that's the idea we are going to use
scale.product
of the WQ
and W K
over what do you call square root of DK.
So this is the scaled outproduct between
the aligned
vectors. So this is what we have so far
and uh we have this scale product that
gives us this similarity. So of course
we need to have a way to learn this Q
and K using enough nonlinearity and then
learn W Q and W K to align them and then
this dotproduct that is scaled will give
us the similarity that matters between Q
and K. So this way we check those case
that are the most similar to Q. Okay. So
let's just move on to compute what we
discussed
that gives us the value of Q right. So
this is that uh in the case of RNN this
is hi but let's just stay um general
here. I'm going to simplify a little
bit. I'm going to call this Q this K and
rewrite this guy in a matrix form for
all Q's and K's and V's. Okay. So
remember that we want to compute the the
kernel regression. If you remember, we
learned the kernel, but we have to do a
soft max over that kernel
and then
uh multiply by vi this gives us this
pooling. And if we write this with this,
it's basically soft max of Q, KT scaled
multiply by V. And this is called
attention which is a function of Q, K
and V. We learn K and Q with enough
nonlinearity. Then WQ and W K that align
them and then pass it to softmax
multiply by the values and that's the
attention pooling. Okay. Next we are
going to code upproduct
attention and show the simplicity of
this idea. But of course we have to
remember where it comes from and why we
can do it because of all of this
nonlinearities that lift our data to a
higher dimension where the linear
operation and linear alignment is
possible and reach enough that gives us
enough learning from data to do the
task. For example, translation or token
generation.